Consider the following
coordinate pairs.
And they give us a
bunch right over here.
Which of those pairs
is not graphed below?
So let's see, 3
comma negative 2.
So 3 comma negative 2,
well, actually, that
looks like that first
one is not graphed.
So 3 comma negative
2 isn't graphed.
And you can verify that
all of these others
do seem to be graphed.
4 comma negative
8 is right there.
Negative 8 comma 3
is right over here.
4 comma 6 is right there.
And negative 1 comma
0 is right there.
So let's do a couple
more of these.
So is negative 5
comma 0 graphed?
Yep.
It's right over there.
Negative 4 comma positive
5 should be there.
So that's not graphed.
So let me just select that one.
Let's do one more of these.
Negative 8 comma 4, so negative
8 comma 4, we got lucky.
The first one is not
graphed-- negative 8 comma 4.
And we're done.